stratford-upon-avon quintessentially
British and the birthplace of playwright
William Shakespeare hundreds of
thousands of tourists come here every
year number nine Church Street is home
to a restaurant of the same name it's
run by Wayne Thompson who is also head
chef we label it contemporary British
which to me means contemporary means
back in fashion never quite gone out of
fashion so reintroducing dishes or
ingredients from the past card for
example is very popular in Britain
the food I feel comfortable with it's
you know it's about freshness it's about
quality of ingredients and seasonality
and not over complicating things in
keeping with that concept he buys
vegetables from the next village for a
local farming cooperative sells freshly
harvested produce Thompson comes here to
shop several times a week he buys
everything from potatoes to parsley the
fact that he hasn't traveled too far
distance to come to the store and then
on to my kitchen means the quality stays
intact so that's a key especially with
no like potatoes once they're in store
they store too long too much starts
develops and there's too much sugar in
the potatoes and that's when you get
soft and soggy chips and fresh is better
and with the freshness Comes equality
today the chef is preparing three kinds
of card for us
the first fill it goes into the frying
pan it's fried on both sides until
golden brown
then it's time to prepare the cod cheeks
years ago there's probably a you know a
wasted by product for me it's probably
the best piece on on the card or the
Tirpitz it's absolutely lovely the fish
is covered with breadcrumbs and then
deep-fried but you could also use a
normal frying pan finally the chef cooks
some cod and hot milk together with
fresh herbs when it's ready he passes it
through a blender together with mashed
potatoes under way to serve this
traditional fish it kind of represents
what we do along the time at number nine
taking these dishes at that I've been
maybe abused in the past and reinventing
a making them special again the puree
forms a bed for the vegetables and the
other two pieces of god
it's served with a great British
favorite parsley sauce the leaves are
blanched and then placed in ice cold
water that way they stay nice and green
then the partially is pureed and white
wine and cream are added to taste
over the last steadily over the last 15
20 years the profile of British cooking
has been raised you you only have to
look at how many restaurants now hold a
Michelin star or two or three you know
and gradually it's it's getting better
and better his high standards are also
upheld when it comes to the upkeep of
the restaurant itself Wayne Thompson
wanted to keep as much of the original
charm of the four hundred year old
half-timbered house as possible number
nine attracts tourists and locals alike
and is further proof that British
cuisine is nothing to sneer it bit
closer